[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you know for people who haven't read the
book like you know about that process
then about
um you know what did it
you know you literally are like you know
starting about like driving out of there
like how did that feel what did you I
think in the picture there's a picture
of there right there I took a picture
because we had this team my team
you know and uh and we were very Senior
Team we were probably one of the oldest
teams that that there were at in marsac
at the time and um
so we were all kind of like on the edge
of like
pulling shocks and uh so I said I got my
DD214 when I left the building which is
an eerie feeling because you turn in
your badge you get your paperwork and
you walk out and the door shuts and you
couldn't get back in how long are you
and Marine up at the up until that point
12 years 12 [ __ ] years and
everybody's like well I just do eight
more years I'm like you stand in your
[ __ ] head for eight more years like
like that's a long that's like it
literally is like okay you just got
eight more years in this in this
Penitentiary no bro like eight years a
long time when you're doing that kind of
work
um and I was just I was done man I was
turning into the and I talked about it
in there I was turning into that grumpy
disgruntled senior dude
like where I just [ __ ] hated
everybody
and I just it I just I didn't like the
person that I was becoming what what
specifically at that point like what was
pissing you off about people everything
like can you give me an example like can
you give me the gamut I mean like they
say something and I'm like you know and
you got to keep in mind like this is the
military there's a very political right
you know some Officer says something and
you're like you're and I and I got to
the place in my career where I was like
you're a [ __ ] idiot you're gonna get
people killed so you've seen that and I
would no I would say that to them right
so you've seen that like you've seen
that kind of [ __ ] you're an officer
but I've seen what you're talking about
I have so much there was a major and I'm
like that you're [ __ ] dumb and you
don't know what you're talking about
you've only you've done this job for a
year I've been doing it my almost my
entire career like you're gonna get
people killed this is stupid this is not
what Special Operations does
that doesn't come but it's not not
really received well but you know when
your staffs aren't telling some major to
[ __ ] off but and uh so that's where I
was kind of getting I was like ver I'd
push the limits a lot and that's funny I
just did this uh one of my my former Ops
Chief uh Master Gunners master gunner
Monroe stuber I just did a podcast with
him on my podcast and we talked about
that and he was laughing he's like yeah
Nick you push the envelope a lot in your
career everybody knew who you were
because I was just like [ __ ] you know
if it was something was stupid I just I
wasn't the guy you know how you get in a
group of people that are all bitching
about something right yeah yeah and then
it's like they get in a group and
everybody's like all right is there any
problems what are we going to talk about
here and everybody's like looking at
their feet and [ __ ] yeah and I was like
I'll tell you what the [ __ ] I was like
I'll tell you the [ __ ] problem
everybody here is [ __ ] tired
we're talking let's talk yeah and then
and then they go is that how everybody
feels and they're all looking at their
food and I'm like what the [ __ ] man yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that I was that guy I
just didn't have that kind of fear to
not talk yeah which also led me you know
got me in trouble a lot but
that's kind of where so the more that
happened the more stupid [ __ ] that would
go on I would just there's one time that
I got in trouble I just went and talked
to the general
they were like these were the rules and
then this other guy was like no we're
not doing that I'm like [ __ ] that's
the rules
that's what we're doing he's like no
we're not doing that so the general
shows up I'm like yeah I gotta like
anything you want to talk about like
yeah I got something to talk about boom
boom boom boom and are these things like
these things that you're having issue
with are they yeah so like one was uh
like helmets we had guys getting shoot
shot in the head and we were using we
were using the 2002 ACH Mitch which
we're not you know they were only
ballistically uh protective up to a
certain point and there's this new
helmet that was cheaper that wore better
was safer and and was had more ballistic
protection
and
they were authorized for use all
throughout Socom except our Command some
[ __ ] random jackass just decided no
though you guys just want to look cool
I'm like no
we have dudes getting shot in the head
this guy meanwhile this guy doesn't
doesn't go to combat right he's not in
the fight he's an administrative
position
and
he's like no you guys aren't just gonna
look cool we have how much you're going
to use those I'm like these people are
getting there's dudes getting killed
wearing these helmets and you're seeing
it it's like guys I know yeah it's like
and you're so I guess Divine one thing
that's always very common and I think
that then transitions to when you you
get back is like one common thing that I
hear a lot about uh guys in this
community is that like people who who
who who aren't there that don't have the
experience that don't see it they don't
smell it feel it they're not living
they're making the decisions for those
of us that do and again it's part of
this podcast it's part of like the same
frustration it's like we are listening
to the wrong [ __ ] people it's like
the people with experience with boots on
the ground really The Good the good and
this General was was one of our best
um General favor he uh he really was one
of one of the best generals that MARSOC
ever had
um
and he would listen and that's why
before he we were in Afghanistan before
he took over the command we were in
Afghanistan and he came and talked to
our teams before he even took command he
was in another command got a flight came
to our base to talk to us before he even
went and took over the amazing
leadership yeah because he wanted to
know what the real [ __ ] was going on the
real problems how we were being treated
operationally and you know
administratively and would you say the
Crux of the things that were frustrating
you were those things people who didn't
know making decisions 100 it was so what
happened you know the issues that MARSOC
had initially was they didn't you know
no the Marine Corps didn't have a
special operations from a
leadership senior officers they didn't
have the leaders they didn't have the
experience in Special Operations so they
got a bunch of these conventional guys
that came down it's like one of this one
of these guys was a conventional guy and
he's like making the rules for us but he
doesn't he doesn't know anything
so like the helmet thing came up and you
know we've gotten multiple guys getting
shot in the head and he's like no you
guys just want to look cool I'm like no
I want the gear to watch your [ __ ]
mouth yeah I want the gear to be
functional Colonel yeah you know what I
mean I want people I wanted to save
people's lives I want the mvgs to sit
right you know what I mean so that we
can we're not like
trying to like go through a freaking
house at night and shit's falling all
over the place and I I guess the re the
reason why I asked the question is
something I haven't really thought of
before but it's like I I you know like
I know where it's going with you right
like where the story's going and like so
many of the so many folks that I've I've
talked to but does that like develop
this sort of
um disdain or like this for folks who
just haven't felt so then you get back
and you're surrounded by this world of
like fast food and then people talk
about talk [ __ ] and you're just like
shut the [ __ ] up why do you go live your
life man like you don't get a seat at
the table you don't get a vote here
right because you haven't lived it enjoy
your life stop talking [ __ ] to me or
saying how I should be or anything like
that because that like God that you're
not that like you're becoming it's like
then you get back and it's like you
think that's all going to end and it's
ratcheted the [ __ ] up so so back on that
that conversation in general so I go
tell them I'm like so there's another
thing like you know guys having beards
like when we when we go there
if you show up with a clean shaven face
you look like you you're like you're a
little you look a little cute walk over
here little boy you know what I mean and
we're supposed to be commanders there
yeah so there's there's supposed to be a
like a 30-day allotment all of Socom
does it but this one random dude was
like no you guys just want to look cool
it's not it's not an operational
requirement no [ __ ] it is
because we have to go command so when we
showed up we had a 314-man surrogate
Army can't be showing up looking like a
bunch of babies but these guys have been
fighting War their whole life but way
more longer than we have right
we have to be we have to play the part
right it's it is act you're acting right
you are acting as if you are been in the
fight just as long as them and you're a
commander those guys that you're talking
about the uh can you give me an example
it's just something I'm can you give me
an example of a former like one of those
guys that you met who who also embodies
heroicism or like you know this is a
kind of a different take on it but do
you remember the uh the 12 strong movie
yes so probably one of the first movies
that I've watched that accurately
depicted the
the relationship between a military a
military service member or Special
Operations guy and then the tribal
leader like he looked at him as like you
have no experience here you are a baby
like I've been fighting War this whole
time that's the relationship and if you
don't show up if you don't show up in
the right frame of mind
with that experience you're not going to
be respected and now you got to lead
these people
like it's a must
you felt off the Jump you probably I got
as much to learn from you as you gotta
learn from me not in a way yes because
the the local terrain like local terrain
and that kind of thing but because I had
been you got to keep in mind like by
this time I've been experienced right so
there was there was a lot I had a lot to
offer and I commanded you know a lot of
our guys commanded respect and we got to
keep in mind like I was bigger than I am
now right like we walked in there they
thought we were [ __ ] Giants right
right right right right and
um so we commanded respect but it but we
knew how to play the part we knew what
role we had to play and we had younger
guys on the team that that were learning
that like we had to teach them like this
is the role You're Gonna Play and
there's some young guys that couldn't
grow beers and stuff and they did get
made fun of right right they're like oh
you're sweet they're like touching their
cheeks and [ __ ] which I'm sure they
appreciated I'm sure those guys right
you know sure but
can you think can you give me an example
of a Brotherhood that was formed in that
way or absolutely friendship because I
mean we you're talking about we're the
the
were War Fighters he's a war fight
around the world we had former Taliban
guys working for us
and you can look at him and tell like I
got pictures I got pictures and it's
funny man I got this one picture it's
like a rug like this there's no couches
of course we're all sitting on the
ground there's like RPGs there's you
know suitcases full of money freaking
AKs all over the place and we're having
we're having taught you know chai and
talking about how we're gonna crush the
enemy
put together okay former Taliban guys
sitting there talking about how we're
gonna take back our villages
[Music]